>>Narrator: Many people think of 4-H
clubs as kids with cows, but in fact,
4-H has been a leader
in technology education
since the early nineteen hundreds.
Back then, adult farmers
resisted adopting new discoveries
in agriculture, but educators found
that kids were eager to experiment,
and would share the
new ideas with adults.
4-H became a way to introduce new
agriculture technology to America.
>>Cecilia: These ones.
These ones right here.
>>Narrator: Today, that
tradition continues
in Washington County, Oregon.
>>Luis: Testing.
>>Narrator: Where one
prominent 4-H project is known
as the Intel 4-H Tech Wizards.
>>Student: Do you wanna
make it go fast, right?
>>Narrator: Here, young people
are being introduced to careers
in science and technology through
Lego robotics, video production,
Web 2.0 and a geographic
information system community mapping.
>>Student: -- practicamos
approximalamente una semana antes--
>>Lisa: They learn skills
after school with us a couple
of hours a week, and
fifty hours of content,
actually, during a year's time.
>>Cecilia: I told them that we're
gonna try and test the robot.
>>Lisa: We have professionals
in the field
who mentor the high school students
and the high school students mentor
younger students in all kinds
of topics that have
to do with science,
technology, engineering or math.
>>Student: We want it to move when
you clap, then it will do that.
>>Narrator: The eighty
six percent drop out rate
and under representation
in the fields of science
and technology among Latino youth
motivated business, government
and community groups to join with 4-H
to create the program
in nineteen ninety nine.
>>Teacher: [speaking Spanish].
>>Lisa Conroy: All the programming
that we do meets the
Oregon diploma requirements.
It's workforce development,
but it's also exposure
to careers and education pathways.
>>Cecilia: [speaking Spanish].
>>Narrator: For some students, the
program makes them feel at home
in their schools for the first time.
>>Lucy: I think especially
the newcomers feel
like they're not part
of this institution.
They come here to learn English.
So a program like this, because
it's done in their native language,
primarily, it allows
them that connection.
>>Narrator: Schools identify
kids who might have an interest
in the program, and
students apply to join.
>>Lisa Conroy: It's a
combination of youth intra space,
and then the community
comes forward with mentors,
professional mentors,
and real world projects.
And then, of course,
we spend some time
in the classroom teaching skills.
>>Cecilia: So if you wanna make
it stable, you need to-- yeah.
>>Narrator: Students apply their new
skills to valuable community projects
such as a street tree survey
for the city of Hillsboro,
in which they use GIS technology
to create a digital
inventory of the city's trees.
>>Lisa: So we really have the
capability to have the kids see
that what they learn is directly
connected to their communities,
and that they can be a community
resource, engaging in that community,
to make a difference in the future.
>>Teacher: So we have
two computers right now.
We're broadcasting live, [Spanish]--
>>Narrator: Continuing
the 4-H tradition,
students share their new ideas
and technology with adults.
>>Luis: [spanish]
>>Cecilia: We are celebrating
the achievements of the students,
the high school students.
They come here and they show
their projects to their parents.
>>Luis: This right here, it's
got the brain of the robot.
It's called the brick.
And what the brick is, it
handles all the information.
All the information of the
program is stored in the robot.
>>Lisa: Ninety five percent of the
kids who are in our program graduate
from high school, and
seventy percent of those go
on to post high school education.
And we're very proud of
the fact that fifty percent
of the participants are females.
>>Cecilia: We have a lot of support
from the parents in the community
because they believe in the program
and they see the changes
their children have made,
and that tells a lot.
>>For more information on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org